[Music]
Selena Gomez is spreading awareness
about mental health by sharing her own
struggles obviously I'm very vocal about
working on that part of you I think it's
important the wolf singer is all smiles
as the cover model for the March issue
of Harper's Bazaar inside the glossy
Selena opens up about her world win 2017
and making it a priority to put her
health first in 2018 quote I've had a
lot of issues with depression and
anxiety and I've been very vocal about
it but it's not something I feel I'll
overcome adding I think it's a battle
I'm gonna have to face for the rest of
my life and I'm okay with that
earlier this month Selena completed a
two-week treatment for depression and
anxiety in New York a source tells ET
quote she did this to ensure she
continues on a good path it's super
responsible on that note Selena says
she's focused on cutting back on social
media for the sake of her well-being
quote I have a complex relationship with
Instagram to say the least
probably one of the most difficult
relationships a reminder Selena is the
most followed person on the platform
with more than 130 million fans I like
to choose to live my life in a way where
I want to be wait free
[Music]
you